hey what's up Samuel lids here and this
is Q&A Sunday where every single week
I'm going to be answering questions
which I'm reading in my YouTube comments
so if you haven't asked any of your
questions yet then comment below let's
have a look at some of these questions
that have been sent to me on YouTube
okay this is from Hollywood kill9 does
it make sense to come from Germany to
one of your crash courses yes
I'm studying real estate industry in the
second semester I know that in Germany
there are a lot of other formulas and
rules that doesn't attach in the UK so
my question is your crash course is it
specifically designed for Britain real
estate market I'm watching your videos
now since five months
keep on doing what you do greetings from
Germany you know what Germany and
England are quite similar so we get
people on average we get people from 17
countries represented at the crash
course so people flying from America
Australia India all over Europe so of
course there's going to be some things
that are a little bit different and it's
your job when you're being trained to be
able to say that applies to me that
applies to me that could be a little bit
different but that's even the case in
England like in London and in Birmingham
things are different the economy's
different house prices are different so
yeah Hollywood
kill9 get down to the crash course I
think you will learn a ton you I know
you'll learn a ton and Germany's really
quite similar so just the general
concept of houses and HMOs and you know
it is quite similar so yeah hope that
makes sense I see what else we've got
Simon TV I'm stuck on a two-year no
refinance mortgage it was a first time
buyer mortgage I'm going to try and rent
out as si but I do wonder how mortgage
companies will perceive si income when
it comes to refinance to buy to let
mortgage from my existing first-time
buyer mortgage okay it sounds like
you're a bit confused around mortgages
so a serviced accommodation mortgage is
a different type of mortgage to a buy to
let mortgage so if you are buying a
property with the intent to rent it out
of serviced accommodation you will need
a particular type of mortgage to do that
it's a bit like if you're buying
anything if you're buying a property to
live in the bank will lend you money to
buy that house to live in it they need
to know what the intent is of the house
so they'll give you a residential
mortgage if you're planning on buying it
to rent it out you'll need to get a loan
a mortgage which is a buy to let them if
it's going to be a hecho mo the loan the
mortgage will be need to be a mortgage
as the properties are hmm
same with service accommodation now the
problem is is when you're fluid with
your strategy so you're saying you're
refinancing it you're wondering if
you're gonna do as I say if you're a bit
fluid of your strategy if you've bought
it with the intent of living in it but
now you want to rent it or you bought it
with the intention of renting it but now
you want to do it as a missed
accommodation you're gonna either need
to refinance it to a correct kind of
mortgage so get a new loan a new
mortgage and just say hey this is what
I'm doing or tell them the situation and
get consent so if you own a buy to let
property and you want to do it as
service accommodation just say to them
hey look here's what I'm wanting to do
and sometimes they won't give you
consent to do that depending on how
strictly mortgage company is but Kim
Reliant's are very very landlord
friendly so good luck and hopefully
that's helped alright let's see what
else we got peach I love some of these
names I'm a bit of a random question
would you go for an interest-only
mortgage or a repayment I'm 24 years old
and unsure what to do any help would be
much appreciated
I'll go interest-only definitely
interest only especially if you're young
because here's the thing if you buy a
property and you pay back the interest
plus repayments what's going to happen
is it's gonna you're gonna sacrifice
your monthly cash flow and your number
one incentive when you're starting out
in property needs to be to become
financially free and the definition of
financially free is to have a high cash
flow each month so you're much better
off to have interest only pay the
absolute minimum payments on
more visas and then give yourself as
much cash flow as you can then when you
become financially free and you're like
oh my goodness I don't need to work and
then what happens is you move to the
next level which is you begin you begin
to become a wealth builder where you're
trying to just grow your portfolio just
kind of for fun and at that point if you
want to stop paying mortgages down then
by all means do that some people are
worried about that because in their mind
they want to pay off the mortgage as
fast as possible but in my mind that's
stupid you don't want to you don't to be
debt free you want to be financially
free
so I hope that helps okay maybe just one
or two more questions so I've had quite
a few questions about the lease option
agreement I've done some videos on lease
option agreement so if you don't know
what that is
click the link above and you can watch
about what it is so this person
clarkey sam says what happens if you get
a lease option agreement sorted for a
house and then say eight years later the
current owner of the house refuses to
honor the agreed sale price DG agreed to
pay one hundred thousand pound then
eight years later the owner has seen the
house is now worth at one hundred and
forty thousand pound and therefore does
not want to sell at one hundred thousand
pound
presumably the option agreement is
legally binding so the current owner has
little choice would it be prudent to
offer a token gesture above the agreed
price in order to avoid cost of fighting
it through the courts etc okay thank you
for your question coffee Sam very very
straightforward I've actually been in
the situation whereby I have agreed to
buy a property from a from an owner on a
lease option agreement and after X
amount of years and then they try to
pull out when they've seen how much the
house has increased and if you've got it
drawn up properly they do not have a leg
to stand on so they can't pull out and
there's no call cost so they can't they
can't like if they take you to court
they have to pay to be honest they won't
even take you to call they might think
about taking you to court but there it
will be their solicitor will say I
cannot defend you because this is
legally binding so it's it's a fear that
you do not have to fear unless you do
not get the contract drawn up properly
and
you get the contract drawn up properly
you need to have the seller legally
represented by a solicitor when the
lease option agreement is drawn up but
sometimes people get really confused
about this because their thing or only
the sister for rent to rent and don't
rent around is a bit different because
you're not actually buying the house
you're just controlling it where is the
lease option you're actually buying it
so it's almost a buy now pay later so
yeah no there's nothing that the seller
can do you're completely safe you have
the option not the obligation but he has
the obligation so hope that clears
things up in terms of lease option
agreements there's another couple people
that have said stuff so we've had FIFA
vids for you say why on the planet would
any seller ever do at least option along
I get it awesome for the buyer but not
for the seller it has no positives a lot
of people have been saying this they've
been seeing some of the lease option
agreement that I've been doing securing
requires no money down good cash flow
each month why on earth would a seller
possibly give you their house for free
and the answer is simple the answer is
that the seller does not want the
property any more they're not interested
in the money I just don't want the house
and usually there's no money in the
house anyway so negative equity property
that properties are very common whereby
the value of the house might be a
hundred the mortgage outstanding on the
house is a hundred so if the seller sold
it today for full market value you'd
have to use all the money to paying off
the mortgage company anyway so he's got
no money in the property it's all debt
so to someone like this landlord passing
it to you where you buy it for a hundred
and ten thousand pounds but in five
years time is attractive to him now you
might say well why doesn't it rent out
himself and then make the monthly cash
flow well the answer to that is he
doesn't want to be a landlord in fact
before I ever take on a lease option
agreement I always recommend that they
rent out themself first and give them
you know the best advice for them if
they have different incentives and
different inclinations and motivations
and then
want to be a landlord and then it won't
the house then all happily take it on
for free on a lease option agreement and
start benefiting from monthly cash flow
and stop benefiting from any capital
appreciation that happens so why would
anyone do it because they don't want the
money now or they can't get them now
because there are negative equity and
they don't want to be a landlord and
they don't want the hassle or stress of
buying the house so there we go there we
have it it's a wrap I want more
questions I want more questions so if
you have niggling questions about
property I want to know your current
situation I don't know what your
question is I want to know what your
obstacle is I want to help you so please
do comment below to this video with your
questions and I'll look forward to doing
another Q&A Sunday next week